die polizei hat getwittert dass es sechs
tatorte gibt und die täter mit
langwaffen also mit gewehren unterwegs
sind können sie für uns noch einer sagen
was das für eine bedeutung hat wie groß
also dieser terror anschlag tatsächlich
ist mit solchen zielen also das ist
richtig ich würde trotzdem sagen wir
müssen vorsichtig sein gerade in einer
situation ist auch die polizei manchmal
überfordert wie frau dadurch gerade
gesagt hat die polizei sieht manchmal
dinge ihr werden und dinge berichtet die
sie dann später nicht unbedingt immer
als korrekt erkauft 2016 in münchen zum
beispiel war es auch so ich kann mich
noch gut erinnern
etwa eine stunde nach dem attentat hieß
es auch von der polizei auf twitter das
ist vier männer mit langwaffen gibt das
ist stück schönster haben stachus gäbe
und das hat sich dann später alles als
falsch herausgestellt deswegen also auch
selbst wenn die informationen von der
polizei kommen muss man vorsichtig sein
wenn sich diese information als korrekt
herausstellen sollten dann ist das
natürlich eine ganz dramatische fast
unglaubliche situation 66 anschläge oder
66 tatort gleichzeitig leute die mit
gefährlichen waffen durch die stadt
laufen das hat es in wien seit 40 jahren
nicht mehr gegeben in wien hat ist sein
ungefähr 40 jahren kann dauer anschlag
mehr gegeben und das hat es orten europa
in letzter zeit eigentlich seit brüssel
und paris nicht mehr gegeben also das
wäre schon eine eskalation wenn es sich
denn tatsächlich als korrekt
herausstellen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren